[Music]
the loud house is one of the most
popular Nickelodeon shows ever but even
a popular show sometimes just can't get
it right wait until you hear which loud
house episode sent a shocking and
totally wrong message to its viewers
don't forget to hit that notification
bell to never miss another video and be
sure to check out our community section
for even more fun now let's check out
some of the loud houses most
embarrassing moments sweet and sour
saying their parents get lovey dovey is
never a thing any kid enjoys and we
definitely didn't enjoy it when our
cartoon mom and dad played a game of
Marco Polo in the sweet and sour episode
of the loud house yeah that's one of the
few embarrassing moments by Rita and her
husband these two decided to have a
moment of fun that later got them kicked
out of their hotel and if it wasn't
embarrassing enough to hear them
screaming Marco Polo we later see them
do the same thing again at the end of
the episode the two are trying to decide
whether they should tell their kids why
they really got kicked out then they
decide that they should know once
they're older not now and of course they
raced their hot tub where once again
they do the questionable Marco Polo
things they're definitely not meant for
kids seriously this is one of those
moments you really never want to watch
again because it's just too embarrassing
when we have a feeling there
would be even more embarrassed and they
learn with their mom and dad really did
in that hotel twinkle you know that is
way too much information let's just go
to the next moment lock and loud locking
out is one of those episodes with a
purpose to teach kids about the
importance of security everyone wants to
be safe in their own household so this
episode definitely highlights an
important issue all kids should be aware
of but there's one specific moment that
totally ruins the seriousness of this
episode hell actually there's two
there's that moment with Rita and Lynne
senior in a bush after they come from
their father and dance class we're
telling you the parents just can't
control themselves in the loud house no
wonder they have so many kids but the
other very questionable moment comes
from Lisa loud Lisa is a special kid as
is but she has some really strange
interests in this episode Lisa seems to
want to enhance her own security system
by performing a slightly inappropriate
skin on her family members and then she
adds she also wants a certain sample
that refers to the number two in the
bathroom well let you figure that one
out for yourself this embarrassing joke
carries on for way too long this it even
gives her mother a pat-down and blurts
out that she'll still need those samples
we also know that she has a security
camera system installed in the bathroom
which let's be honest it's just way too
bizarre funny business funny business is
one of those episodes that make you feel
really bad and embarrassed for Lincoln
the kid really does represent what it's
like being the middle child of a family
we hate that he does it so well it seems
like just about anyone picks on him even
complete strangers in this episode
Lincoln becomes louann's clown assistant
the ends up totally stealing
that's not what's embarrassing about it
even a Lincoln is pretty hilarious as a
clown what's cringe-worthy is the fact
that the Goths and all the parents
really don't treat Lincoln well in this
episode they really aren't on board with
Lincoln's jokes at all and instead pay
all the attention to LuAnn the parents
even say that they never want to book
the funny business company for their own
kids party because they don't want the
kid to hate them now that's kind of mean
isn't it a lot of fans expressed that
this particular episode just made them
angry because Lincoln really didn't
deserve this treatment and for what it
looks like it's the treatment he gets
all the time he really does play the
stereotypical middle child but we do
hope that he eventually catches a break
brawl in the family a deviantART user
called super blue guy wrote this long
essay of his least favorite loud house
episode and his arguments are so
convincing we're having a few in this
video one of those episodes is called
brawl in the family this episode is
embarrassing from the plot perspective
where once again
Lincoln becomes the butt of all jokes it
seems like the loud sisters just can't
get enough when it comes to hating on
Lincoln and blaming him for practically
everything
the deviantART user states it's unfair
that the sisters put so much blame on
Lincoln when in reality a lot of things
they blame him for or really their own
responsibility come on
Lincoln can't enter the kitchen just
because Lori and Lenny are cooling off
from a fight even tries to make peace
between them but it unfortunately causes
them to fight again it really isn't his
fault but he ends up getting blamed for
just about anything talk about unfair
even the parents aren't putting their
foot down but are actually preparing
separate dinners just because the two
sisters can't get along you know it's a
cartoon world but come on what does this
teach kids making the grade seriously
can Lincoln ever catch a break we really
hope that no middle kid gets picked on
or gets such bad luck as Lincoln does a
lot of loud house episodes are supposed
to be taken with some sense of humor
there are just some that are way too
shocking making the grade is one of
those episodes TV arts super blue guy
but this episode is number two of his
top six worst loud house episodes list
this episode also had plenty of moments
that could easily make you feel
embarrassed whether it's for Lincoln or
the entire show seriously Lincoln's
friends abandon him
just because his much younger sister
attends his class and appears to be
smarter than everyone Lisa and Lincoln
have a lot of adorable moments together
for her basically turning away all his
best friends is not one of them it
really makes you feel for Lincoln and
facepalm at the writers of this show
come on Kim Lincoln be something other
than the butt of every joke it seems
that even some of the most hard-core
loud house fans are noticing the
treatment he gets in these episodes
hands up if we should make a video
showing some of Lincoln louts best
moments because he definitely deserves
it along came a sister but enough about
Lincoln it seems that the adults of this
show just can't help themselves every
time they open their mouth they do
something embarrassing or say a joke
only an adult could understand remember
miss Johnson Lincoln's teacher in this
episode Lincoln gets to bring home Frank
the class pet tarantula the embarrassing
moment happens when mrs. Johnson
explains what Lincoln needs to know
about taking carrot Frank
she says that Frank needs to be fed
twice a day and can't be let out of the
cage under no circumstances but then she
adds something even adults watching the
show would find embarrassing her facial
expression softens and she leans back on
her desk with a mesmerizing look she
then says that this tranch allah is
unlike her because she'll definitely be
out of her cage when she goes away for
the weekend adults will definitely know
what she meant by that statement
okay mrs. Johnson it's already weird to
know that teachers have a life outside
of school and this is just TMI for the
kids inside the classroom and those in
front of the TV
talk about an embarrassing moment this
one really does take the cake doesn't it
a novel idea
Uranus jokes are getting old but
apparently not for the loud house of
course this could be a totally innocent
joke except that most kids these days
are actually totally aware but it really
means a novel idea has a weird plot
where once again Lincoln gets the short
end of the stick Lynne senior hosts a
take your daughter to work day and
invites all loud how sisters except of
course Lincoln Lincoln is so bummed out
by this even tries to dress as a girl so
he could go but it doesn't work out his
dad's office doesn't even do a take your
son to work day
gets the same treatment we're really
starting to see a pattern with a loud
house and Lincoln's character but that's
not what's embarrassing about this
episode
when Lincoln ends up at his mom's dental
office he has to play around on the
dental chair he pretends to be an
astronaut flying into space of course
Lincoln makes a joke saying that he sees
Uranus and that's pretty gassy get it
Uranus gassy we love a good pun but come
on Lincoln you can do better than that
the loudest yard
okay this moment really just wasn't
necessary allowed how sometimes throws
strange moments with a sense of humor no
one really understand you and kids can
cringe at some of the stuff they see on
TV the loudest yard has one of those
moments we all know Lincoln loves to
play video games and spend time inside
which is not exactly ideal Rita ends up
taking matters into her own hands and
decides Lincoln needs some exercise and
this is what's disturbing about this
episode rita puts on a home workout
video in the living room and tells
Lincoln that exercise can be fun you can
see Lincoln standing right behind his
mom and while his mom thinks Lincoln is
exercising he's doing something totally
different it seems like Lincoln is
staring at his mom's behind well he
actually is because he taped a comic
book to it and he's now reading the
comic book instead of properly
exercising we got it we really do but we
feel just a little weirded out a
facepalm and a cringe are in order for
this one we can't imagine seeing anyone
doing that in real life without it being
totally bizarre get the message okay
this episode isn't so bad as a whole the
beginning part still gives us nightmares
it's one of those things we never want
to see again and yet here we are because
we have to show it to you and get the
message Lincoln does what he does best
which is playing video games
he gets totally into it as he bounces
around with his VR game and tries to
defeat the bad guys but instead of just
keeping it at that like it has no
problem showing off some of the most
embarrassing moves ever
sorry link but you know these are bad
this is totally inappropriate for kids
but you can actually see Lincoln twerk
his way up the stairs and into Lori's
room which as you might know is a
totally bad idea
seriously nickelodeon couldn't he use
any other moves and in case you're not
embarrassed just
this is not the last time Lincoln shakes
is behind on this show the inappropriate
jokes are always popular with a loud
house that doesn't mean they don't make
us feel totally embarrassed what do you
think appropriate or inappropriate heavy
metal and the winner of the most
embarrassing moment on the loud house is
the episode heavy metal our friend Devia
art user super blue guy but this episode
is number one on the top 6 worst loud
house episodes list many fans have
expressed mixed emotions over this
episode and we feel them what's really
embarrassing about this episode is the
way the loud house is handling bullies
we all see that Ronnie Ann is the one
bullying Lincoln yes the same Ronnie Ann
that ends up admitting to having a crush
on Lincoln just a couple of episodes
later while we're always taught that if
people pick on you it usually means that
they like you this could totally send
the wrong message to kid after all not
all bullies are the same the child
should know that they can report the
bully to school authorities at any time
we wanted to talk about the fact that
Lincoln's sisters make the entire
situation much worse even though
sometimes teasing can be done out of
love it's just wrong to state that the
bullying is just a simple act of love
and that the child should never report
anything to the school what do you think
do you have a least favorite loud house
episode Monty let us know in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]